we do have big news that I don't want to
go overly crazy about because of how it
will probably turn out the big news is
that Donald Trump's former national
security adviser one of trumps former
national security advisors john bolton
one of the architects of the Iraq war
says he's willing to testify in the
Senate impeachment trial of Donald Trump
he says he would do it if he is
subpoenaed that's typical in these
situations to say you will show up if
you are subpoenaed because you don't
want to be accused of willingly showing
up to bad-mouth someone but it's not
totally clear that that's actually what
john bolton would do we just don't know
bolton said in a statement yesterday
quote i have concluded that if the
senate issues a subpoena for my
testimony I am prepared to testify now
of course whether he would be subpoenaed
by a Republican Senate is a real open
question Republicans are likely to run
the trial as Mitch McConnell has
admitted in the way that's most
beneficial to Donald Trump after Bolton
and Trump's falling out it's very
difficult to imagine that a Bolton
testimony would actually be in Donald
Trump's interest but nevertheless Trump
Bolton rather publicly saying this does
put some pressure on Republicans to
bring him in now Marco Rubio Republican
senator from Florida came up with a
completely cockamamie excuse for why he
doesn't think Bolton should testify it
was something about I'm paraphrasing
here I think he said it's a Manu Raju of
CNN it was something along the lines of
well the impeachment articles were based
not on John Bolton's testimony so I
think that the impeachment trial in the
Senate should be based on the same
things that the articles were voted on
in the house sort of saying like if
Bolton wasn't part of the proceedings in
the house he shouldn't be called in the
Senate it was ridiculous you know a
number of different legal analyses say
it makes no sense whatsoever now as an
update the president has been impeached
by the House of Representatives Speaker
of the House Nancy Pelosi has not yet
sent the articles of impeachment both
there's two of them to the Senate which
is required to get the trial going
remember that John Bolton previously
declined to participate in the houses
Pietschmann investigation saying that he
was directed by the Trump administration
not to comply with Congress he said if
you subpoena me if federal courts uphold
the subpoena I will testify the
committee's ultimately did not issue a
subpoena for his testimony now there is
something interesting about the subpoena
of john bolton many things in the senate
require a two-thirds majority to impeach
a president and convict them in the
senate you need a two-thirds majority
you need two-thirds of senators meaning
67 of the hundred senators to vote to
convict right now there are 45 Democrats
and two independents who caucus with
Democrats that's 47 votes in the Senate
you would need 20 Republican senators to
vote to convict in order to remove
Donald Trump not likely to happen to
subpoena john bolton you need only a
simple majority meaning 51 senators that
means you need the 45 democrats the two
independents who caucus with democrats
bernie sanders and angus King and then
just for Republicans to sign on to
subpoena john bolton you actually could
make this happen if we go to our
standard list of republicans who might
do something logical you've got susan
collins from maine you've got lisa
murkowski from alaska you've got maybe
mit romney from utah people talk about
over about what about cory gardner from
colorado it's possible the idea of
Bolton being willing to testify if
subpoenaed is also funny if you were
subpoenaed you were required by law to
show up there talking about it like it's
a choice and he would make the right
choice
now that's an issue that maybe will come
up if Bolton is unwilling to respond to
the subpoena or if it is challenged by
the White House and it goes to federal
courts but Donald Trump clearly will do
what he can to prevent john bolton from
ultimately testifying imagine being
bolton who has loved the idea of war
with iran for so long and now trump
waits until you're gone before trying to
start a war with iran he must just be
furious in his neocon boots don't you
think now as far as people getting super
excited about Bolton's testimony even if
he's
p-nut and even if the subpoena is upheld
by a federal court and Bolton has to
testify he could choose to obfuscate
unimportant issues he could plead the
fifth on important issues Bolton will do
what is best for John Bolton and that
might be showing up an obfuscated it
might be showing up in self aggrandizing
it might be showing up and saying
nothing this guy is not only is he no
hero he's really one of the villains of
American foreign policy over the last 20
years and of course of the Iraq war the
only good thing here is that it puts a
little bit of pressure on Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell to allow
witnesses because otherwise it would
look like they are trying to silence
Bolton which they probably are but once
again if there's no consequences for
silencing John Bolton why wouldn't they
do it it wouldn't make a difference what
if I told you that you could read eight
books in one afternoon
that's essentially what one of my
favorite apps allows you to do it's
called blinka stand you can try it
totally free for a week and get 25% off
a subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman blink Asst takes
thousands of best-selling non-fiction
books gathers the most important info
and insights from each book presents
each book to you in the form of a
condensed ebook or audio book that you
can consume in just 15 minutes there are
only so many hours in your week blinka
stakes it possible for you to absorb the
most valuable takeaways from nonfiction
books that you otherwise might not have
a chance to read I've just finished
listening to upheaval by Jared Diamond
Jared Diamond a tremendous author whose
work I've previously recommended
excellent book looking at some of modern
history's biggest national crises to
figure out how different countries ended
up in such precarious situations you can
use blink Asst
to get through a topic quickly and
efficiently it's really useful if you
just want to explore a certain topic but
don't necessarily want to commit to
reading the entire book about whatever
it is and a premium subscription is only
about eight bucks a month which gives
you unlimited access to every single
book that they offer they have books on
politics economics philosophy science
you name
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 2020
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you